now finally washington
has seized that oh russia and china
really are allies they've been hoping
that that hasn't been true for for many
years right up until the ukrainian
crisis but they are allies and our
job number one for us you know is is to
be prepared to defeat this
block this totalitarian power block
uh that is coming you know they are a
bigger threat to us by far than nazi
german in the imperial japan world world
war ii you know because they can destroy
our homeland now did you just say their
bigger threat oh yeah the nazi in
germany was in world war the nazi
germany and imperial japan combined and
it and fascist steadily combined because
the the those the totalitarian powers of
that day could not reach across the
oceans they couldn't project power
across the ocean now they can and they
could destroy our society in 30 minutes
and all their even even their allies and
we should by the way when a country gets
nuclear missiles you really need to
think of them as a superpower